what's the deal with airplane
peanuts Bill bur standup in movie form
this is a quote from Bill bur's longtime
business partner describing his new
movie titled old dads after being
delayed for the past 6 months due to a
number of speculated reasons that we'll
get into later this video Bill Burr has
finally set a release date for the
Netflix film that is largely based on
his life story this movie that you've
made is a subject that's near and dear
to your heart it's about being dads
older dads right old dads D there was
something that came about by you know
not getting my together and having kids
really late in life like I'm 54 my kids
are 5 and 2 I didn't realize like how
much the world had changed like my
daughter's in kindergarten now and I was
in kindergarten 50 years ago so just the
whole way that they teach like
everything literally i' be like oh
you're on the jungle gym and she'd be
like it's called the structure and and
then I'd be like yeah and then I'd be
like oh my God I said jungle am I you
know did that said borderline racist now
like what did I just say and you just
start freaking out over the past few
years Bill burs put together a very
respectable acting resume making guest
appearances in shows like Breaking Bad
and The Mandalorian as well as creating
his own Animated Series F is for family
but due to some dire onset circumstances
this new movie required Bill bur to step
into an all new role for the first time
in his career filming for old dads
started during the pandemic in 2020 and
every major director was booked up
without a director the entire project
was in Jeopardy and in order to not lose
the opportunity for this movie to get
made altogether bill had to step in and
save the day making his director debut
strictly out of necessity the level of
work that directing is I had no I had no
idea like you have to answer every
single question like this is
when I knew I was in trouble there was
one scene like uh our set director right
lovely person she comes up to me she
goes okay in this scene there's going to
be a barbecue I'm like yeah all right
cool and she goes what are we thinking
paper plates I'm like yeah yeah paper
plates and she goes what kind of paper
plates and I was
just go to Ralph's
if this movie is sounding familiar it
might be because old dads was supposed
to come out a long time ago in fact Bill
Burr first promoted the movie in August
of 2022 during his historic show at
Fenway Park the year-long delay was most
likely due to a change in decisionmaking
when it came to selling the movie to
Netflix but many Reddit users speculate
the push back may have been caused by
Berke Cher's movie The Machine and
Sebastian maniscalco's film about my
father coming out at similar times both
movies included the same overarch ing
premise of a popular standup comedian
turning part of their life story into a
large budget movie ironically enough
Bill Burr leaking the old dad's trailer
during a massive show in his hometown is
almost identical to the way that Berke
ker premiered the machine trailer during
his show in Tampa we showed the trailer
to Old dads people really liked it I
called Sony the company Distributing our
movie I said hey can we move the trailer
date for a week I grew up in Tampa I
think it would mean a lot to show this
trailer in Tampa don't get to it excited
they said no comedians jumping from the
standup world into the movie industry
isn't anything new and although Comics
getting involved in movies can help
produce funnier projects it can
sometimes turn their stand-up careers
into an afterthought it doesn't take a
genius to figure out going all in on
movies will lead to less time writing
performing and trying out new jokes but
this doesn't seem like it will be an
issue when it comes to Bill Burr the
acting the standup or is it yeah it's
something if I can if I can uh the right
thing comes along or whatever but I'm a
comedian I'm a comedian and I want to be
you know but you see I you have interest
you have I do but I also did you the
direct recently and uh yeah and that's
uh I'm not allowed whatever
reason you can't say when it's going to
come out until they tell you I don't
understand like this is just like a
waste of you know opportunity right here
but yeah it's going to be coming out old
dads will Premiere October 20th on
Netflix which is only 58 days away gu
spots from last week The Joe Rogan
Experience had on Terrence Crawford two
bears one cave was Burt and Tom Tom and
Bert killed Tony this week was with Ty
Rivera ymh did not have a guest flagrant
had on Jelly Roll Sam Morel was on hey
babe we might be drunk had on Joe list
Joe list was also the guest on stav's
world as well as whiskey Ginger and
taste buds so you're telling me they're
pushing a new physical media in this day
and age brother 4K is yeah I know about
4K it's been around a long time I have
4K television yeah but but they didn't
have 4K disc these are 4K they do 4K
full transfer the movies look
unbelievable okay so you get a 4K you
get a 4K of a movie that came out in the
70s and you watch it and you're like
this is what it looked like day one in
the theater oh okay I get that okay so
Joe who actually Joe is a filmmaker
himself yes I am a filmaker shout out
there that's correct I just did a I just
did a thing with you we just did a
little program together you we did yes I
I cast you and and I appreciate the
director listening cuz often times
people write like oh who should we get
for this and I'm like oh you got to get
Scoopy Boop and they don't even look as
my working
name this past weekend with Theo Von did
not have a guest the blocks podcast
talked with kumal n Johnny Jim gaffan
was on the Honeydew Trevor Wallace was
on first date take your shoes off with
Rick Glassman talked with Bobby altof
are you garbage had on Lauren Compton
being in with Jordan had on Tom takar
Anthony Rodeo was on you know what dude
Jared freed was on only fans and tiger
belly had on Mark Norman you notice I'm
going right down the middle here between
you two yeah cuz I don't want to be rude
but as he's doing that to you I'm
getting secondhand discomfort too so I'm
looking down and twirling this thing
thank God okay you so I'm when I'm
giving him compliments it's he's
deflecting it to you yeah I feel it so
then I just looked down and TW how did
you feel when he was I was looking at
George oh wow no one was looking at you
yeah no one was looking at me and you
where were you looking I was looking at
you just accepting the compliments as if
they were to me all right why do you
look like a pedophile
mayor
yeah you look like a pedophile May holy
as far as new standup comedy
specials are either out right now or
coming out very soon Joe list enough for
everybody is the big full hour from last
week along with Jared Freed's new
special 37 and single which is top 10 on
Netflix right now we also had 30 minutes
with Dave Smith Premier earlier today on
YouTube Tom tar tar Noir is out right
now on 800lb gorilla and Adam Ray put
out a full special on his channel titled
live from Portland I had to poop it a
Starbucks a few weeks ago and um first
of all they know when you're pooping and
not purchasing so enough with the fake
customer of like hey what's up um
can I get what kind of new beans do you
guys got can I just get a straw to go
bag ice Grande they're like hey man it's
224a don't break anything in there
there's also quite a few specials that
will be coming out relatively soon the
one every comedy fan has circled on
their calendars is Shane Gillis who
recently confirmed that his new hour
will be uploaded sometime before
September 11th what a terrible name for
an airline it reminds me of that tragedy
speaking of upcoming specials that have
already been filmed but not yet released
there's quite a few Comics falling into
that category right now such as Nick
Mullen Trevor Wallace and Whitney
comings Matt mccusker's debut standup
special the speed of light has
officially surpassed 1 million views on
YouTube which is dope as hell
congratulations to Matt I'm putting out
one of the best hours of the year
whether it's brand new specials or
random podcast appearances it's it seems
like there's more content coming out of
the comedy world now than there ever has
been and it's definitely getting harder
to keep up with all your favorite Comics
that's exactly why you should subscribe
to joke world right now to stay in the
comedy Loop and if you need comedy News
on the go all of these episodes are
available to be downloaded wherever you
listen to podcasts thank you for
watching this video and for the love of
God please check out our Instagram you
bastards we have 14,000 Instagram
followers and 300,000 YouTube
subscribers it's the same content go
follow us on Instagram and if you're old
and you're like I don't have an
Instagram we're on Facebook
now joke
world that's did it joke
world and the world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out